peu de la sixième à la première un
programme savamment composés propose aux
lycéens
l'étude des matières mais plus variés il
y a ceux qu'on aime et ce qu'on n'aime
pas il ya ce qui paraît utile
il y a aussi ce qui paraît inutile mais
l'examen qui sanctionne les études
interdit de travailler seulement selon
ses préférences
c'est un peu ce bilan critique que nous
avons fait avec l'aide de quelques
étudiants par easyjet en première au
maire
quelles sont les matières qui vous
paraissent est plus utile à votre vie
future
c'est à dire que théoriquement c'est les
mathématiques ce serait là la science
naturelle car j'aimerais être chirurgien
mais cette infection le sua section m
j'ai fait pareil ou surnaturel j'ai
pensé physiques et les longues part
également aux points de vie culture
générale je pense que le français
l'histoire et géographie l'instruction
civique sont importantes
il y at-il matière considéré comme
secondaire qui vous paraîtrait justifié
un enseignement plus importante la
gymnastique
ces moyens de missiles en est que
quelques pauvres aux heures de
gymnastique
lorsqu'on secours le prendre
de mathématiques
je pense qu'on exige beaucoup les études
culturelles il ya très peu de notions
générales même vague à part pendant les
cours de français et encore c'est très
alors que souhaiteriez-vous comment deux
heures par semaine on est un programme
beaucoup plus étendue et une vie culture
soit en peinture soit dans l'armement en
vie quand même en musique cette assembly
définissez l'intérêt que porte à chacune
de ces matières l'histoire l'histoire ou
enfin j'aime j'aime bien l'histoire
parce que ça retrace quelque chose de
vivant ne pas d'un roman pour 12 d'un
roman c'est pas trop théorique
il faut la prendre parce que comme un
peu connaître l'histoire de son pays il
veut apprendre l'histoire les plus
étranges et aucun intérêt pour moi
elle nous permet peut-être de comprendre
la politique actuelle de la france
pourquoi dites-vous peut-être
peut-être si on s'attache surtout si
et et aux conséquences pour apporter les
différents faire ma géographie
le jeu graphie j'aimerais ça c'est si je
prenais mes n'avons pas grand-chose en
géographie
j'aime bien je me suis posé qu'une
émission
et idiot logique il est utile de
connaître les différents pays du monde
la france les sciences naturelles sens
naturel l'enjeu
j'ai pas beaucoup les sciences
naturelles ses sorties si pour moi je ne
suis nulle en dessert
j'aime étudier mais je n'aime pas
la pythie la physique la physique c'est
comme le silence surprenant ses matières
préférées
pourquoi
tous un passionnant d'être capable de
comprendre une machine et
est obligé de recourir à d
application de typhaine est utile de
savoir je suis pas remettre des plans ou
quelque chose comme ça la chimie
très peu il ya trop de formules les
mathématiques ça n'a pas d'intérêt pour
vous ça offrant un intérêt dans le but
vous savez que ça offre un intérêt le
sait mais enfin oui c'est ça fait poser
travaillait pas simple personnellement
ça ne se travaille pour l'examen parce
que je pensais enfin
[Musique]
non mais tu trouvais pas de joie en
aucune façon il faut la prendre pour
compenser le bac c'est utile c'est
difficile
ça donne une certaine tournure d'esprit
quel genre de tournure d'esprit retenir
d'esprit logique la littérature la
littérature j'aime beaucoup la
littérature à littérature c'est un
plaisir ce n'est plus une nécessité à
j'aime beaucoup
autant lycée qu'à l'extérieur où c'est
nécessaire pour des génies qu'est ce que
ça apporte la littérature d'abord de la
conversation ce qui n'est pas
négligeable et ensuite pour son plaisir
personnel c'était nous c'est une
richesse ça nous permet de connaître nos
contemporains et ceux qui sont venus
afin de s qu'il forçait et parle à avoir
une idée sur les différents problèmes de
l'existence les langues et donc par
action pouvant voyager juste prix c'est
indispensable
c'est important parce qu'on ne te
connaître les étrangers par conséquent
l'homme en général quand pouvant parler
avec lui le lapin je n'en ai pas fait et
heureusement je trouve que c'est une
qu'on devra faire avec les classes ça
nous apprend
réellement la racine des mots français
qui nous aide pour les langues latines
c'est de plus un intérêt pour moi parce
que cela ne servira pas plus tard et
depuis je trouve ça préserve
ça développe la télé j'ai un souci il
faut réfléchir l'éducation physique a
très important j'estime qu'il ya eu un
net progrès pour cela et c'est vraiment
nécessaire autant aux garçons que
j'étais
pour être un homme pompe l'air il faut
être bien aussi bien physiquement que
moralement
étudiez vous une matière selon votre
goût selon les nécessités de l'examen
ben j'essaie de me forcer à l'étudier
sans insister l'examen seulement
j'ai quand même remporté par mango
malheureusement c'est mon goût
et vous êtes reçus aux examens that is
the question
c'étaient les élèves de première et que
pense maintenant les élèves de
mathématiques élémentaires demoiselle
vous êtes sans classe de mathématiques
élémentaires
quelles sont parmi les matières que vous
étudiez celles qui vous intéressent le
plus
les mathématiques et en dehors des
mathématiques la philosophie pourquoi
parce que je trouve précédemment
dérivatif lorsqu'on fait des
mathématiques c'est très intéressant
je regrette même pendant presque trois
heures il y at il une matière considéré
comme secondaire qui vous paraît
justifié un enseignement plus important
et pourquoi
dans la classe de mathématiques on ne
doit pas se perdre trop de différences
encore
trop de séparation pour les matières
piqué littéraire on pourrait peut-être
donner plus d'importance
à l'histoire la géographie et un
philosophe études et vous une matière
selon votre goût selon les nécessités
l'examen j'étudie soleil
la différence
vous être sur votre examen jusqu'à ma
fille il faut absolument combiner les
deux si vous aviez la possibilité
d'établir un programme selon vos goûts
quelle matière vous paraîtrez le plus
intéressant et le plus utile
mathématiques philosophie
pas d'histoire des mathématiques
[Musique]
l'histoire les mathématiciens n'ont pas
rêvé de changer le monde et les
philosophes
quelles sont les matières qui vous
paraissent le plus utile à votre vie
future
ben j'ai l'intention de faire médecine
pour être assez paradoxale si fait philo
donc les sciences nat
ma foi la physique sont obligés de
de l'apprendre qu'est ce que vous voulez
faire un terreau fait
y at il une matière considéré comme
secondaire qui vous paraîtrait justifié
un enseignement plus important l'anglais
programme
il de savoir une langue étrangère et en
philosophie remet à fait pour ainsi dire
pas on fait beaucoup jusqu'à la première
mais
parce que quand c'est à dire je trouve
qu'on devrait accorder beaucoup plus
d'importance à la culture générale vous
devrez faire s'est intéressé les élèves
beaucoup plus à la musique
la mâture
ca c
dix heures de cours de philosophie par
semaine en classe de philosophie sont
aussi intéressés par sion si passionnée
par ce serait ce sera vraiment
fastidieux
qu'est ce que nous avons qu'est-ce que
vous entrez
j'en tire le résultat finalement elle
n'est pas il est pas évident mais ça
vous permet surtout d'apprendre à
réfléchir ça vous permet d'essayer de
comprendre les problèmes de la vie des
problèmes de dispose alors étudié vous
une matière selon votre goût selon les
nécessités de l'examen au selon mon goût
et du temps et vous réussissez à votre
examen
jusqu'à maintenant ça a marché c'est à
dire je ferais concilier les deux parce
que évidemment si je pouvais consacrer
tout mon temps les philosophes ferait
seulement des matières comme l'histoire
la géographie
je suis obligé de l'est
les études y est c'est une par
obligation par obligation j'aimerais
pouvoir étudier de manière sûre
et là je suis en train de
de les apprendre essentiellement pour
l'examen si vous aviez la possibilité
d'établir un programme selon vos goûts
quelle matière vous paraîtrez les plus
intéressantes il est plus utile
philosophie anglais
deux régions graphie
mais que latin
qui concerne l'art
bien classe de philosophie puisque les
ceux qui sont en philosophie normalement
en vente à la faculté des lettres ou à
la faculté du droit ou sciences
politiques devraient être bien sûr la
philosophie doit être la lira de la
littérature qu'on ne fait pas ça devrait
être
l'histoire
la géographie est une langue étrangère
ou de langues étrangères mais beaucoup
moins de chance quelles conclusions
tirer de ce sondage rapide
les lycéens qui ne paraissent pas très
révolutionnaire souhaite une culture
générale plus profonde et pour répondre
aux exigences du monde moderne
une étude des langues plus poussée
[Musique]